how's it going everybody it has been an
exciting week for the MCU and the DC EU
more along the DC EU because there's
just been a lot of news recently but
still nonetheless very exciting week so
in this video I'll be taking you through
all the news that came out that you need
to know to stay up-to-date in the MCU
and and the DC EU first we'll get
started with the MCU we'll talk about
what happened at Cinna Europe this week
we'll talk about Captain Marvel and
Avengers 4 then we'll talk about the DC
EU will talk about Wonder Woman 1984
we'll talk about Aquaman Shazam and San
Diego comic-con coming up and we'll even
talk about Superman so first things
first cinah Europe was this past week
and they showed footage of Captain
Marvel and Avengers for a few brief
scenes of Captain Marvel was shown to
the audience which emphasized her as a
character and her powers so here's
basically the rundown of what was shown
and what Marvel has to say about her
character
they say that Carol Danvers aka Captain
Marvel is the MC used most powerful hero
and she's set to become the new face and
leader of the MCU moving forward also in
an interview brie Larson who is the
actress that plays Captain Marvel came
out and said that Captain Marvel is
strong enough to move planets so they're
going all out with Captain Marvel and it
makes perfect sense because if they want
to stand any chance against defeating
Thanos they're going to need a powerful
character such as Captain Marvel and
then there's a footage that was shown
about Avengers 4 unfortunately right now
there are two different reports from
what happened at Cinna Europe it seems
like half of the leaks say that there
was footage of Iron Man and Ant Man
coming together going through the
quantum realm and going throughout time
collecting Infinity stones footage is
basically done for Avengers 4 and it is
highly believed that time travel and
jumping through the quantum realm is in
fact the plot of Avengers 4 so this is
probable but there are other leaks
coming in that say the Avengers 4 clip
was nothing but Marvel Studios President
Kevin Feige
in the chair saying sorry to the
exhibitors for there being so few heroes
left to sell their customers now this
could just be misdirection because we
definitely saw that for Avengers
infinity war a lot of misdirection was
thrown out there by the producers but
there's really no way of knowing what
the actual plot of Avengers 4 is gonna
be until we receive a trailer for it and
unfortunately that probably won't happen
for another few months so that's it for
the major MCU news let's now move on to
the DC EU a lot has happened with the DC
EU this week and a lot of it is Aquaman
thanks to Entertainment Weekly we have
received our first look into Aquaman and
with that came a first look at many of
the characters that we haven't seen yet
on the cover the two issues we got are
another look at Aquaman and mera and we
got our first look at Nicole Kidman's
Queen atlanna then inside we have our
first look at some of the scenes that
are going to be in Aquaman
we have Arthur curry aka Aquaman
seemingly in a submarine then we have
Aquaman and mirror on land we finally
got our first look at Patrick Wilson's
arm staring right into the eyes of
Aquaman himself
we got a behind the scenes shot from the
movie that has Aquaman and mera meeting
with Willem Dafoe's volcko but you can't
really see his face so that's kind of a
tease we got a first look at Queen
atlanna holding a young Arthur curry
which means that we're definitely going
to be exploring his origin a little bit
and finally we got our first look at
Black Manta these are the first photos
that have actually shown us scenes from
the movie and with these new photos came
talk about the trailers release date
Aquaman director James Wan had this to
say comic-con will be insane this is the
new glyph slash logo freshly smuggled
out of Atlantis stolen off King Arms
belt buckle so it seems like it's
probable that we're going to get the
first Aquaman trailer during San Diego
comic-con which takes place from July
19th
to the 22nd since Marvel will actually
not be attending San Diego comic-con
this year it has been said that DC has
some very big plans in store with those
big plans we will most likely get the
Aquaman trailer but we will most likely
get something on Shazam as well and
connecting to Shazam in a way
is Superman Henry Cavill took to social
media today announcing that he is
working on his super buns while he
shared a video of him working out and in
his description of the video he left
some not so subtle hints of him
returning to play Superman not too long
from now but we haven't gotten any
announcement about Man of Steel - and
justice league - is still a no-go for
now so it leads us to believe that he's
gonna have a cameo in Shazam this rumor
has been going around for a while now so
maybe we'll see this happen at San Diego
comic-con and last but certainly not
least is we saw our first look at Wonder
Woman - or Wonder Woman 1984 as it is
officially titled
we saw some interesting photos this week
we saw Diana Prince aka Wonder Woman
living her life in the 80s and we found
out that Steve Trevor is alive and well
it seems that he must have been
preserved somehow because it doesn't
seem like he aged 60 plus years then we
got some photos of Chris Pine and gal
gadot on the set and it seems like
Wonder Woman is well underway with the
filming and finally today we were given
our first look at gal gadot as Wonder
Woman in her Wonder Woman outfit so that
is it for the major MCU and DC EU
announcement that happened this week
what are you most excited about are you
excited about Captain Marvel coming in
and being the strongest character in the
MCU or are you excited that it seems
like the DC EU is making it comeback or
at least trying to as always let me know
your thoughts in the comments below I'd
love to hear from you and if you enjoyed
this video please click that thumbs up
button also be sure to subscribe to my
channel so you don't miss any updates on
the MCU or the DC EU thank you so much
for watching
woof woof
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]